[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24 la
justicia peruana dictó detención
provisional por espacios de siete días
contra el expresidente Pedro Castillo
quien es investigado por presunta
comisión del delito de rebelión entre
tanto el presidente mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador confirmó que Pedro
Castillo solicitó asilo político en su
país a través de la representación
diplomática mexicana en Lima
entre tanto la presidenta de Perú Dina
boluarte en unas declaraciones a la
prensa descartó adelantar elecciones en
Perú Indicó que su prioridad es
reorientar al país la mandataria también
confirmó que Perú será la sede de la
Cumbre de la alianza del Pacífico y
reiteró la invitación a su homólogo
mexicano que no la ha reconocido como
mandataria
El Congreso de Estados Unidos aprobó un
proyecto de ley que busca blindar a
nivel Federal el proyecto de el
matrimonio igualitario de esta manera se
busca proteger un derecho y evitar un
escenario como el que tuvo lugar con la
revocatoria de la ley que permitía la
interrupción del embarazo a nivel
Federal
Muy buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González vamos a comenzar esta edición
de noticias en Perú en donde el juez
supremo Juan Carlos chicle ordenó siete
días de detención provisional para el
expresidente Pedro Castillo investigado
por presunta comisión del delito de
rebelión previamente conversamos con
nuestro corresponsal en la capital
peruana Francisco Zacarías y nos dio más
información en torno a este tema
escuchemos
el juez Juan Carlos chefle validó la
posición de la fiscalía que señalaba que
para tener éxito el delito de rebelión
no era necesario que esté consumado Qué
aconteció es que la fiscalía venía
señalando que Pedro Castillo hizo una
violación flagrante de la
constitucionalidad y el orden
democrático y al disolver el parlamento
y convocar a las fuerzas armadas para
que respalden sus medidas extremas esto
constituía el delito grave de lo que se
conoce se está hablando en estos
momentos de Conspiración y también de
rebelión Esto fue rebatido por la
defensa de Pedro Castillo que señalaba
que no puede existir el delito de
rebelión ni tampoco de Conspiración
porque para que eso se constituya se
requiere el alzamiento en armas Pedro
Castillo no se alzó de armas y tampoco
violentó Al parlamento Pues bien pues
Juan Carlos cheque luego de oír las
ponencias terminó por apoyar la posición
de la fiscalía es así que Pedro Castillo
va a tener que
tener una detención preliminar por siete
días en la prisión de barbadío donde es
compañero de celda del ex presidente
Alberto fujimori Francisco Zacarías
informándonos desde la Ciudad de Lima
también hay que decir que el presidente
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador
afirmó que él ya expresidente peruano
Pedro Castillo solicitó asilo político
en México lo hizo a través de la
representación diplomática mexicana en
la capital peruana de otra parte la
presidenta Dina boluarte en unas
declaraciones a la prensa local Indicó
que entiende los pedidos de diferentes
sectores de adelantar elecciones a lo
que la mandataria respondió que la
prioridad de su gobierno en este momento
es reorientar al país boluarte también
confirmó que Lima se mantiene como la
sede de la Cumbre de la alianza del
Pacífico que ser realizada la próxima
semana la nueva mandataria reiteró su
invitación al presidente mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador quien ha rechazado
la destitución de Pedro castillo y
todavía no reconoce a boluarte como la
nueva presidenta de Perú
como ahora ya no hay una vicepresidenta
que pueda quedarse Al cuidado del
despacho presidencial y pueda viajar a
recibir este encargo tan importante para
latinoamérica esperemos que en todo caso
el presidente amlo como había ofrecido
venir al Perú se pueda cumplir esto acá
lo vamos a esperar con los brazos
abiertos y con el cariño de todos los
peruanos y si no estaremos haciendo vía
zoom la entrega de la presidencia Pro
tempore para el Perú después de la
destitución de Pedro Castillo Perú está
inmerso en una nueva fase de turbulencia
política lo que revela una vez más esos
antiguos y profundos problemas de
gobernabilidad en los últimos años la
política peruana ha estado marcada por
una serie de crisis de escándalos de
casos de corrupción que han llevado al
país a ver nada más y nada menos que
seis presidentes en solamente seis años
en seis años Perú ha tenido seis jefes
de estado en 2020 el centrista Francisco
sagasti fue investido como presidente
para garantizar la transición tras la
destitución de Manuel Merino quien duró
menos de una semana en el poder el
derechista ex jefe del Congreso se vio
obligado a dimitir en medio de protestas
contra su gobierno un Éxodo de su
gabinete y numerosas peticiones por su
dimisión
Merino reemplazó a Martín vizcarra quien
fue destituido por el congreso en 2020
después de que medios de comunicación
informaran que recibió unos 640 mil
dólares en sobornos por parte de dos
empresas que ganaron una licitación de
Obras Públicas cuando era gobernador
regional años antes en 2018 Pedro Pablo
kuczynski se vio obligado a dimitir de
la presidencia bajo la presión del
Congreso la fiscalía había abierto una
investigación en su contra por favorecer
contratos con la constructora brasileña
odebrecht cuando era ministro bajo el
mandato de Alejandro Toledo kuchinski
negó inicialmente Cualquier relación con
odebrecht jefe de estado acabó
admitiendo que su consultora había
asesorado a la constructora en 2016 el
presidente ollanta humala fue a juicio
por acusaciones de que recibió 3
millones de dólares por parte de
odebrecht durante su campaña
presidencial de 2011 los fiscales
pidieron 20 años de prisión contrahumada
que siempre negó las acusaciones
las dos veces medalla de oro del
baloncesto Britney greiner que había
sido condenada 9 años de prisión por la
justicia de Rusia fue intercambiada por
Víctor Wood el llamado mercader de las
armas un extraficante de armas
considerando el mayor de la historia hay
polémicas respecto a la decisión que ha
tomado Washington tomada en medio del
contexto de la guerra en Ucrania y
porque el intercambio de la deportista
fue realizado por un reconocido
delincuente más en el siguiente reporte
es libre así lo confirmó el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden escoltado por
la esposa de kriner su vicepresidenta y
el secretario de estado hace un momento
junto a su esposa sherell en la oficina
oval hablé con Britney wriner está a
salvo está en un avión está camino a
casa
grainer campeona olímpica de baloncesto
fue detenida en Rusia el pasado mes de
febrero por tener aceite de Cannabis en
su equipaje al entrar a ese territorio
en agosto fue condenada a nueve años de
cárcel por Contrabando y posesión de
drogas Estados Unidos ahora enfoca sus
esfuerzos en la liberación de Paul
Williams un exmarin acusado de espionaje
también arrestado en la nación
euroasiática el pasado 2018 después de
meses de detención injusta en Rusia está
de camino a casa con su esposa cherrell
y otros de sus seres queridos nos
estaremos en nuestros esfuerzos hasta
que Paul William también regrese con su
familia Britney fue intercambiada por
quien era considerado los hombres más
buscados del mundo el ciudadano ruso
Víctor void un Traficante de armas
conocido como el mercader de la muerte
en otros temas El Congreso de Estados
Unidos aprobó un proyecto de ley que
busca blindar a nivel Federal el
matrimonio igualitario el texto protege
la ley en caso de que el tribunal
supremo decidiera revocar ese derecho ya
adquirido como ya lo hizo con el derecho
a la interrupción del embarazo la cámara
de representantes de mayoría demócrata
validó el proyecto con 258 votos a favor
y 169 en contra después de que el senado
se hubiera pronunciado en la misma línea
el pasado 29 de noviembre con 61 votos
positivos y 32 votos de rechazo ahora
solamente se espera que el presidente
Joe biden lo ratifique para que entre en
vigor a nivel Federal
hoy defendemos los valores que la gran
mayoría de los estadounidenses aprecian
una creencia querida una creencia en la
dignidad la belleza y la divinidad La
chispa de la divinidad en cada persona
un respeto permanente por el amor tan
poderoso que une a
nos vamos ahora hasta el continente
europeo porque sigue la atención al
interior de la Unión Europea después de
que el gobierno de Austria vetara o
votara en contra de permitir el ingreso
de Rumanía y Bulgaria al espacio de
libre circulación de personas y
mercancías de la Unión Europea una
postura que apoyó los Países Bajos solo
en el caso búlgaro en respuesta el
Ministerio de exteriores de Rumanía
convocó a la embajadora de Austria en
bucarest y para esto para advertirle que
el veto de Austria tendrá consecuencias
inevitables en las relaciones
bilaterales la negativa tiene lugar Pese
a que tanto la comisión europea como el
parlamento europeo ya habían pedido en
diferentes ocasiones que los países
votaran para permitirle el ingreso a
Rumanía y a Bulgaria que Son miembros de
la Unión Europea pero aún no son
integrantes del tratado de libre
circulación conocido como tratado
Y empezamos todos Bueno como siempre lo
hemos hecho todos los días número 8 del
mes Recordando el secuestro del
periodista francés Olivier dubá en Mali
este 8 de diciembre del 2022 ya se
cumplen 20 meses desde que fue raptado
en nombre de la libertad de prensa
también en apoyo a su familia a sus
personas más cercanas y a sus familiares
en nombre de France 24 le seguimos
dedicando nuestros pensamientos hasta
que llegue su Liberación allí en el
continente africano con esto llegamos al
final de las noticias en France 24 siga
con nosotros
[Música]